This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars Beautiful Radio Meaning you do not see the picture, you hear the voice. Here's something called the box you mana. Here's the human voice. The voice is radio. Involves the audience, fire more than television, every year. This is WJK, Monday, March 12, 1973. Thank you, and here's some more hidden music. Take 20 now, people. This is Big Jetter.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美丽的广播意味着你看不见画面，只能听到声音。这里有一些被称为“盒子”的东西。这是人类的声音。声音就是广播。它比电视更能吸引观众。这是WJK，1973年3月12日，星期一。谢谢，这里还有一些隐藏的音乐。现在开始第20条，各位。这是大杰特。
I don't know where to canon land. Here we go. There are those innovations that everyone loves and depends on. You're biggies like computers, electricity, the printing press, and then there are the innovations that made you who you are. Punk rock music, photocopiers, cassettes, non-chucks. But if I were to rank them, I think the two most important technological innovations to my life are broadcasting in home sound recording. And today I have two of my favorite stories from two of my favorite any productions all about the early days of broadcasting and recording.
我不知道该在哪里着陆。我们开始吧。有些创新是每个人都喜爱并依赖的。比如电脑、电力、印刷机这些大家伙，还有一些创新塑造了今天的你。朋克摇滚乐、复印机、卡带、双节棍。但如果要我排名，我认为对我一生最重要的两项技术创新是广播和家庭录音。今天，我带来了我最喜欢的两个故事，来自我最喜欢的两个制作团队，都是关于广播和录音的早期历史。
Radiotopians, radio diaries, and the kitchen sisters represent a best of what we can achieve in audio storytelling, and here they are tackling the subjects that are near and dear to my heart. These pieces were first broadcast on NPR as part of the Kitchen Sisters' Lost and Found Sound series. First up, with his story of Conrad's garage and the birth of commercial broadcasting in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, this is Joe Richmond from Radio Diaries, produced in 2001. produced in 2001. The sounds that came out of Frank Conrad's garage in 1919 and 1920 are gone. There were no recordings made, and everyone who participated in those weekly broadcasts has died. In fact, there may be only one person still alive who actually heard what was going on
Radiotopia、Radio Diaries和Kitchen Sisters代表了我们在音频叙事方面所能达到的最高水平，他们正在探讨我内心深处非常关注的主题。这些作品最初是在NPR作为Kitchen Sisters的“失而复得的声音”系列节目的一部分播出的。首先，由Radio Diaries的乔·里士满带来关于康拉德车库和匹兹堡商业广播诞生的故事，制作于2001年。1919年和1920年从弗兰克·康拉德车库里传出的声音已经消失了。当时没有留下录音，所有参与那些每周广播的人都已经去世了。事实上，可能只有一个人还活着，他曾亲耳听到过当时发生的事情。
in that garage. A man named Harry Mills. This is K4HU. Hello Charlie. W1HVA here's K4HU. How are you this evening? Hi, I'm Steve Goodman. I'm a little sleepy. Harry Mills is 94 years old. He was an engineer for RCA most of his life, but for the last eight decades he's been going on the ham radio just about every day.
在那个车库里。一个叫哈里·米尔斯的人。这是K4HU。你好，查理。我是W1HVA，这里是K4HU。今晚好吗？嗨，我是史蒂夫·古德曼。我有点困。哈里·米尔斯今年94岁。他一生中大部分时间都是RCA的工程师，但在过去的八十年里，他几乎每天都在使用业余无线电。
Mills first discovered radio in 1919. He was 12 years old, and his parents bought him a copy of the Boy Scout Handbook. In the book, after a lot of the camping and setting up a tent in a rain and helping the old lady cross the street and so on, and the back was a chapter on how to build a wireless station. I had never heard of such a thing. So I built one. I'll show you how it works. It was built out of photograph plates and tin foil, a condenser, and this is weather stripping.
米尔斯在1919年首次发现了无线电。他当时12岁，父母给他买了一本《童子军手册》。在书中，除了大量的露营、雨中搭帐篷、帮助老太太过马路等内容外，后面还有一章关于如何建立无线电台。我以前从未听说过这种东西。所以我建了一个。我来演示一下它是怎么工作的。它是用照相底片和锡纸、一个电容器做成的，这是防风雨条。
And this is a Ford Coil, Ford ignition coil which would hook onto your antenna and your on the air. This is what radio sounded like when Mills first started, the Dopp's and dashes of Morse code. That's the letter V, which you use for test purposes. If you hear me, he'd come back and we'd hold a conversation as simple as that. Almost every night Harry Mills would line his bed and listen to the amateur radio operator signal back and forth. Then one night he heard something different. I remember with 10 or 11 o'clock at night and all at once this voice appears. And I remember letting out a yoke or a shout of some sort my dad do it, who just got out of the bass,
这是一个福特线圈，福特点火线圈，把它连到天线上，你就上线了。这就是米尔斯刚开始接触无线电时听到的声音，莫尔斯电码的滴答声。那是字母V，用于测试目的。如果你能听到我，他会回复，我们就这样简单地进行对话。几乎每天晚上，哈里·米尔斯都会躺在床上，听着业余无线电操作员发出的信号。然后有一天晚上，他听到了一些不同的声音。我记得是晚上10点或11点，突然间这个声音出现了。我记得我发出了一声惊呼，我爸爸也听到了，他刚从床上起来。
come in wrapped in a toutus for sure I was all right. Somebody hadn't happened to me. And I said, dad, look, I'm hearing this full of talking. And we shared the headphones, only had one pair of headphones. And he allowed us, I was right. Harry Mills had stumbled onto the experimental transmissions coming from Frank Conrad's garage, 35 miles away. He was talking to me, says, now I'm going to play a phonograph record, and he did.
他裹着浴袍走进来，确定我没事。以为我出了什么事。我说，爸爸，看，我听到了这个人在说话。我们共用耳机，当时只有一副耳机。他听了之后，发现我是对的。哈里·米尔斯偶然听到了从35英里外的弗兰克·康拉德车库传来的实验性广播。他在跟我说话，说，现在我要放一张唱片，然后他就放了。
It was his time then. I didn't know you could be that. I began with that and heard voice before, and I dropped the music. It opened up a whole new world. Frank Conrad was not the first person to talk and play music on the radio. Inventors like Reginald Fessenden, Lee DeFarrist, and Mark Honey have been doing such experiments as early as 1906. But back then, radio was seen as a method of one-to-one communication, like the telegraph. Few envisioned radio is a way to reach many people at the same time, to broadcast.
那是他的时代。我不知道还能这样。我以前从未听过人声，然后我放了音乐。这开启了一个全新的世界。弗兰克·康拉德并不是第一个在广播里说话和播放音乐的人。像雷金纳德·费森登、李·德福雷斯特和马克·霍尼这样的发明家早在1906年就开始了此类实验。但当时，无线电被视为一种一对一的通信方式，就像电报一样。很少有人预见到无线电可以作为一种同时触达许多人的方式，即广播。
Frank Conrad was among the first to use the word broadcasting. It was originally an agricultural term used to describe the distribution of seeds over a large area. In his garage, Conrad helped to change the concept of radio, and he did it largely by accident. Testing, testing, testing, testing one, two, three, test one, two, three, this is Frank Conrad from the garage. This is what it would have sounded like anyway. It's probably fair to say that nobody cares more about Frank Conrad's garage than a man named Rick Harris.
弗兰克·康拉德是第一批使用“广播”（broadcasting）这个词的人之一。它最初是一个农业术语，用来描述在大面积土地上播撒种子。在车库里，康拉德帮助改变了无线电的概念，而且这很大程度上是偶然发生的。测试，测试，测试，测试一、二、三，测试一、二、三，这是弗兰克·康拉德从车库发出的声音。无论如何，这听起来就是这样。可以说，没有人比一个叫里克·哈里斯的人更关心弗兰克·康拉德的车库了。
Harris is an amateur historian who has dedicated his life to preserving and researching the history of that garage. He's collected replicas of the equipment Conrad used. A microphone, made out of the top of a candlestick telephone, mounted in a small box stuffed with cotton, and a hand cranked to Vectrola. You turn the crank. Rick Harris says the story of Frank Conrad's garage really begins with that Vectrola. Conrad was an engineer for Westinghouse, so he had access to vacuum tubes which allowed him to transmit his voice over the air.
哈里斯是一位业余历史学家，他毕生致力于保护和研究那个车库的历史。他收集了康拉德使用过的设备复制品。一个由烛台电话顶部制成的麦克风，安装在一个塞满棉花的小盒子里，还有一个手摇式维克多留声机。你转动曲柄。里克·哈里斯说，弗兰克·康拉德车库的故事实际上是从那台维克多留声机开始的。康拉德是西屋公司的工程师，所以他能接触到真空管，这使他能够通过无线电传输他的声音。
But at the time, Conrad wasn't thinking about broadcasting. He was simply trying to test and improve his transmitting equipment. The problem was his voice after talking endless hours into the microphone would wear out. So he got the idea one day to put on a record that would give him two or three minutes
但在当时，康拉德并没有考虑广播。他只是想测试和改进他的发射设备。问题是，对着麦克风说了几个小时后，他的嗓子会受不了。所以有一天他想到了一个主意，放一张唱片，这样他就能有两三分钟的时间。
to adjust his equipment and would save his voice. This one is an ancient one so I don't know what it's going to sound like. And as soon as he started playing the music he began getting requests for more music and he would get phone calls and letters asking him to play a certain song at a certain time so someone listening with their crystal set could convince a relative that you could actually play music over the air. He found very quickly that there was an unseen audience out there. It would call me up at night and ask me to transmit. They had some friends, one to listen to something coming out of the air.
来调整他的设备，也能保护他的嗓子。这一张是很古老的，所以我不知道听起来会怎么样。当他开始播放音乐时，他很快就开始收到更多音乐请求，他会接到电话和信件，要求他在特定时间播放某首特定的歌，这样用矿石收音机收听的人就能向亲戚证明，音乐确实可以通过无线电播放。他很快发现，外面有一个看不见的听众群。他们会在晚上打电话给我，要求我进行广播。他们有一些朋友想听听从空中传来的声音。
This is Frank Conrad, recorded in the late 1930s not long before he died. And if I got to take care of that, I sort of reigns the same program twice a week. Everyone's in Saturday night. First of that time, and I actually had no idea what was going to end up in doom. Over time, Conrad's garage started to sound more like a radio station. Along with phonograph records, Conrad would transmit piano solos by family members and baseball scores. And then, when he started to run out of records to play, Conrad went to the Hamilton Music
这是弗兰克·康拉德，录制于20世纪30年代末，在他去世前不久。如果我能处理好那个，我每周会重复同样的节目两次。大家都在周六晚上。在那之前，我其实根本不知道最终会变成什么样。随着时间的推移，康拉德的车库听起来越来越像一个广播电台。除了唱片，康拉德还会播放家庭成员的钢琴独奏和棒球比分。然后，当他开始没有唱片可放时，康拉德去了汉密尔顿音乐。
Store and asked to be Guevara's son for his broadcast. The owner said yes, as long as Conrad agreed to announce the name of the store on the air. Slowly, Conrad was building the one thing announce the name of the store on the air. Slowly Conrad was building the one thing the radio industry hadn't yet thought much about, an audience. But the real turning point came on September 29th, 1920, when the Joseph Horn department store placed this ad in the Pittsburgh Sun.
商店，请求他们为他的广播提供唱片。店主同意了，只要康拉德同意在广播中宣布商店的名字。慢慢地，康拉德正在建立无线电行业尚未考虑过的一件事：听众。但真正的转折点出现在1920年9月29日，当时约瑟夫·霍恩百货公司在《匹兹堡太阳报》上刊登了这则广告。
Air concert picked up by radio here. The music was from the vitrola, and the home of Frank Conrad. Mr. Conrad is a wireless enthusiast and puts on the wireless concerts periodically for the entertainment of many people in this district who have wireless sets. Amateur wireless sets are on sale here, $10 and up. The ad really caught the attention of Conrad's boss at Westinghouse, a man by the name of Harry Davis, who the story goes, called Conrad in the next day, and said, essentially, I would like to put you out of business because I would like Westinghouse to set up its own station.
“无线电接收到的空中音乐会”。音乐来自维克多留声机，地点是弗兰克·康拉德的家。康拉德先生是一位无线电爱好者，他定期举办无线电音乐会，为该地区许多拥有无线电接收机的民众提供娱乐。业余无线电接收机在此有售，10美元起。这则广告真正引起了康拉德在西屋公司的老板哈里·戴维斯的注意，据传，他第二天就把康拉德叫去，基本上说，我想让你停业，因为我想让西屋公司建立自己的电台。
And Davis asked Conrad, could that be done in Conrad set of course? So over the next month Conrad and his team began constructing a wooden shack on the roof of the Westinghouse plant. They built a 100 watt transmitter and at 6 p.m. on the night of November 2nd, 1920, the newly licensed station KDKA went on the air. This is KDKA of the Westinghouse Electric and Manufacturing Company in East Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. K went on the air. The station launched by Broadcasting the Returns of the Harding Cox Presidential Election. There were no recordings of that broadcast, but in the late 1930s, the original announcer, Leo Rosenberg, made this recreation.
戴维斯问康拉德，这能做到吗？康拉德说当然可以。于是接下来的一个月里，康拉德和他的团队开始在西屋工厂的屋顶上建造一个木棚。他们制造了一个100瓦的发射机，1920年11月2日晚上6点，新获得许可的KDKA电台开始广播。这是西屋电气制造公司在宾夕法尼亚州东匹兹堡的KDKA。电台通过广播哈丁-考克斯总统选举结果开启了广播时代。那次广播没有录音，但在20世纪30年代末，最初的播音员利奥·罗森伯格进行了这次重现。
We depreciated if anyone hearing this broadcast would communicate with us, as we are very anxious to know how far the broadcast is reaching and how it is being received. Well, nobody ever heard such a thing before, you had to wait till the next day to find out who won the election. Harry Mills, who was 13 by this time, remembers going down to the local newspaper where they had set up a receiving station. Somebody would sit at the receiver and a crowd gathered outside or a number of people
“如果有人听到此广播，请与我们联系，因为我们非常渴望知道广播覆盖的范围以及接收情况。”好吧，以前没人听说过这种事，你必须等到第二天才能知道谁赢得了选举。当时13岁的哈里·米尔斯记得他去了当地报社，那里设置了一个接收站。有人坐在接收机旁，外面聚集了一群人。
and they would watch these returns being updated as the numbers came in bigger. The next day on the newspaper, of course, the talk was, gee, for the first time ever, people were able to get the reports, the talk was G for the first time ever people were able to get the reports before the newspaper was printed. I think it's very difficult for us today to imagine really quite what a magical moment this was.
他们看着这些结果随着数字的更新而更新。第二天在报纸上，当然，大家都在谈论，天哪，这是有史以来第一次，人们能够在报纸印刷之前就得到报道。我认为我们今天很难想象这到底是一个多么神奇的时刻。
Susan Douglas is a professor at the University of Michigan and the author of Inventing American Broadcasting. She says the KDKA election broadcast was a watershed event. And because there were no connecting wires, because there was this concept of the ether, there was kind of a cosmic connection for people. It was a quasi sort of spiritual event that these voices were coming out of the air into your home. And two weeks after that first transmission, Weston House introduced the first radio for the general public, the Aereola Junior, which sold for $25.
苏珊·道格拉斯是密歇根大学的教授，也是《发明美国广播》一书的作者。她说KDKA的选举广播是一个分水岭事件。因为没有连接线，因为有“以太”这个概念，人们产生了一种宇宙般的联系。这是一种准精神层面的事件，这些声音从空中传进你的家里。在那次首次传输两周后，西屋公司推出了面向大众的第一台收音机，Aereola Junior，售价25美元。
The broadcasting boom had begun, and over the next few years, radio would move out of the garage and into the living room. It's KDKAP expert! Wherever you go! Today, KDKA is considered the oldest radio station in the country. History has not been as kind to Frank Conrad's garage. This fall, bulldozers began to clear the site. It will soon be a windies. The bulldozers destroyed Conrad's house, but Rick Harris and a group of supporters
广播热潮开始了，在接下来的几年里，无线电将走出车库，进入客厅。这是KDKA专家！无论你去哪里！今天，KDKA被认为是全国最古老的广播电台。历史对弗兰克·康拉德的车库并不那么友好。今年秋天，推土机开始清理现场。它很快就会变成一个停车场。推土机摧毁了康拉德的房子，但里克·哈里斯和一群支持者。
called the Conrad Project managed to save the garage, piece by piece. The woodwork, all of the doors, the windows, and some 25,000 or so bricks, the ones that survived anyway. I don't know. It's just the more I learn about Frank Conrad and what he did and the fact that he's virtually unknown outside of Pittsburgh. It's just something, it feels that he's been overlooked for what he did.
被称为“康拉德项目”的组织设法一块一块地挽救了这个车库。木制品、所有的门、窗户，以及大约25000块砖，至少是幸存下来的那些。我不知道。我越了解弗兰克·康拉德和他所做的事情，以及他在匹兹堡以外几乎无人知晓的事实，就越觉得他因为自己的贡献而被忽视了。
Someday Harris hopes to reconstruct Conrad's garage and turned it into a museum. Frank Conrad may have helped to launch the modern broadcasting industry, but that wasn't really his vision. Conrad was just a talented engineer, tank-related night in his garage, trying to connect to people through the air. And that pretty well describes what 94-year-old Harry Mills is still doing, every night at 10 o'clock. After all this time, Harry Mills says he still feels the same way he felt when he first
有一天，哈里斯希望重建康拉德的车库并将其变成博物馆。弗兰克·康拉德可能帮助开启了现代广播业，但这并不是他的初衷。康拉德只是一个有才华的工程师，晚上在车库里摆弄设备，试图通过空气与人建立联系。这很好地描述了94岁的哈里·米尔斯每晚10点仍在做的事情。过了这么久，哈里·米尔斯说他仍然感觉和第一次一样。
heard Frank Conrad's voice coming out of the radio. To me, it's difficult to describe the fascination of it. I know I use it all the time. How does it happen? To me, it's difficult to describe the fascination of it. I know I use it all the time. How does it happen? I can't see the fella. No wire is going from here to there, but you can talk to him. It was a phenomenon that interested me from the beginning.
听到弗兰克·康拉德的声音从收音机里传出来。对我来说，很难描述那种着迷的感觉。我知道我一直在用它。这是怎么发生的？对我来说，很难描述那种着迷的感觉。我知道我一直在用它。这是怎么发生的？我看不到那个人。没有电线从这里连到那里，但你可以和他说话。这是一个从一开始就让我感兴趣的现象。
I presume it's safe to say that that is. I've never gotten over it. So with that, I'm going to say good night. Thanks for the use of your loudspeaker. Though good night, Bob, and good night, guys. W-1-T-R-F-K-4-H-U. Okay, very good. Good night. Good night, guys.
我想可以肯定地说就是这样。我从未从中走出来。所以，我要说晚安了。谢谢你使用你的扬声器。晚安，鲍勃，晚安，伙计们。W-1-T-R-F-K-4-H-U。好的，非常好。晚安。晚安，伙计们。
All day long, they are. Good night, all. I love what you want to hear. Conrad's Garage was produced by Joe Richmond of Radio Diaries in 2001 for the Lost and Found Sound Series. Harry Mills, who was featured in that piece, died in 2008. Conrad's Garage is still a pile of loose bricks in storage of waiting its final resting place as a museum, so someday, someday we hope, you'll be able to see it for yourself.
整天都在。晚安，各位。我喜欢你想听的内容。《康拉德的车库》由Radio Diaries的乔·里士满于2001年为“失而复得的声音”系列制作。在该节目中出镜的哈里·米尔斯于2008年去世。《康拉德的车库》目前仍是一堆散落的砖块，存放在仓库里，等待着它作为博物馆的最终归宿，所以有一天，我们希望你能亲自看到它。
[♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ So here's the deal. Radio Diaries has a podcast, it's part of Radio Topia, and recently their stories were featured on this American life and planet money. Joe Richmond, offhandedly, said to me when we were talking about today's show, we'll see if you promoting the Radio Diaries podcast on 99% invisible will result in more Radio Diaries subscribers than Planet Money or T.A.L.
[♪ 片尾音乐播放 ♪] 事情是这样的。Radio Diaries有一个播客，它是Radio Topia的一部分，最近他们的故事在《美国生活》和《金钱星球》上播出。乔·里士满在谈到今天的节目时随口对我说，看看在《99%隐形》上推广Radio Diaries播客是否会比在《金钱星球》或《美国生活》上带来更多的订阅者。
Now I don't know if you know this about me, but I am extremely competitive and so I need everyone hearing my voice to subscribe to the Radio Diaries podcast right now. Here's the thing, you'll get short, fortnightly stories that will blow your mind. Radio Diaries will reach more people than ever and I'll get to demonstrate the power of this bully operational battle station. Everyone wins except planning money in this American life. They're gonna lose. So you got it? Subscribe now.
现在我不知道你是否了解我，但我非常有竞争力，所以我需要每一个听到我声音的人现在就订阅Radio Diaries播客。事情是这样的，你会得到简短的、双周更新的故事，让你大开眼界。Radio Diaries将触达比以往更多的人，我将能够展示这个强大的运营战斗站的力量。每个人都赢了，除了《金钱星球》和《美国生活》。他们会输的。所以你明白了吗？现在订阅。
It's important. Ira is watching. Now I don't want to push my luck here, but there's another podcast that you'll want to subscribe to right now that equally deserves to rock it up the podcast charts. It's called Fugitive Waves from the Kitchen Sisters. And if you require proof of why you need to subscribe to another podcast, well then I have the perfect story for you. This is probably one of the top 10 radio stories of all time.
这很重要。艾拉在看着。现在我不想碰运气，但还有另一个播客你现在也想订阅，它同样值得在播客排行榜上飙升。它叫《逃亡的波浪》，来自Kitchen Sisters。如果你需要证明为什么要订阅另一个播客，那么我有一个完美的故事给你。这可能是史上前十名的广播故事之一。
It was first broadcast on MPR's All Things Considered in 2004. The hosting by No Addams and Robert Siegel is really integrated into the story, so I decided to present it as is. This is NPR's All Things Considered. No, it's not. I'm Robert Siegel. And I'm No Adam.
它最初于2004年在NPR的《万事皆考量》节目中播出。诺亚·亚当斯和罗伯特·西格尔的主持真的融入了故事中，所以我决定原样呈现。这是NPR的《万事皆考量》。不，不是。我是罗伯特·西格尔。我是诺亚·亚当斯。
Stop, guys. Each week we begin our lost and found sound series with this theme. It's called Music in Marble Halls. This improvised duet of clarinetette and High Heels crossing a Manhattan office lobby was recorded in 1962 by New York audio legend Tony Schwartz, one of the most original and eccentric sound gatherers of the century. It was 1945 when Tony Schwartz first stepped out of his apartment with a microphone to capture the sounds of his neighborhood.
停下，伙计们。每周我们都以这个主题开始我们的“失而复得的声音”系列。它叫《大理石大厅里的音乐》。这段即兴的单簧管和高跟鞋穿过曼哈顿办公大厅的二重奏，是由纽约音频传奇人物托尼·施瓦茨于1962年录制的，他是本世纪最原创、最古怪的声音收集者之一。1945年，托尼·施瓦茨第一次带着麦克风走出公寓，捕捉他社区的声音。
Now more than 50 years later, Tony Schwartz has amassed one of the largest and most eclectic collections of recorded sound in the world. The kitchen sisters, producer is Davie Nelson and Nikki Silva. Visited Tony in his Midtown Basement studio, where he's surrounded by tape recorders, mixing consoles, awards, photographs, and row upon row of audio tapes. There's Dore Tony Schwartz, 30,000 recordings later, looks at the legacy of a man who has spent his life exploring and influencing the world through recorded sound, beginning with a work called New York 19 was the non-commercial musical life of my postal zone.
现在50多年过去了，托尼·施瓦茨积累了世界上最大、最不拘一格的录音收藏之一。Kitchen Sisters的制作人戴维·尼尔森和尼基·席尔瓦拜访了位于中城的托尼地下室工作室，那里到处都是录音机、调音台、奖项、照片和一排排的音频磁带。这就是托尼·施瓦茨，在30000次录音之后，回顾一个通过录音探索和影响世界的人的遗产，从一部名为《纽约19》的作品开始，这是我邮政编码区的非商业音乐生活。
And the postal zone was New York 19 at that time. It's 101019 now. That was the area I could travel in. I'm not able to travel far. I have a Gorophobia. And in walking, I could just go around my postal cell and it's still been happened. I made the first portable tape recorder.
当时的邮政编码是纽约19。现在是101019。那是我可以旅行的区域。我不能走远。我有广场恐惧症。在步行范围内，我只能在我的邮政编码区周围活动，而且它还在发生。我制造了第一台便携式录音机。
I brought the VU meter from inside the case to the top so I could look down at it and see how loud things were. I put a strap on it so I could have it over my shoulder. That was 1940. I could go record children in the park doing jump rope rhymes. I recorded the street festivals. I made 14 records for folkways records. You can see them up there.
我把VU表从机壳内移到了顶部，这样我就可以低头看它，看看声音有多大。我给它装了一条带子，这样我就可以把它背在肩上。那是1940年。我可以去公园录下孩子们跳绳的童谣。我录下了街头节日。我为Folkways Records制作了14张唱片。你可以在上面看到它们。
The children's games of the streets, I called it one, two, three, and a zing zing zing. On the macy's and me, more, more, more. There's a big, fat, leech, man at the door, door, door. I was interested in the sound around us. Two things that you're not allowed to carry in taxi. One is fish, the other is bedding, they're both. I had a wrist mic. I had a brush lapel mic and I would put it on a wristwatch band and I'd put it out my sleeve so I would just walk around and record that way like when I went into the pawn shop and I did cab drivers that way recorded
街头的儿童游戏，我称之为《一二三，叮叮叮》。在梅西百货和我，更多，更多，更多。门口有个大胖水蛭人，门，门，门。我对我们周围的声音很感兴趣。出租车里不允许带两样东西。一个是鱼，一个是床上用品，它们都是。我有一个腕式麦克风。我有一个领夹麦克风，我把它放在手表带上，从袖子里伸出来，这样我就可以四处走动录音，比如当我走进当铺时，我就是那样录下出租车司机的。
by 7800 cab drivers. Two way with your parko lots and mid-dial from 14th Street for 59th Street no parking a lot in the daytime only after 6 o'clock. There should be a solvulom. I had recorded the songs on truth boxes in the restaurants or bars that cater to the various groups around my postal zone. What I would do is get people in the restaurant who spoke English to come over and translate it translated for me. The country which I was born is suffering many, many back economic things. Even though I'll feel terrible there.
由7800名出租车司机录制。双向，你的停车场和从14街到59街的中段，白天没有停车场，只有6点以后。应该有一个解决方案。我录下了餐馆或酒吧里点唱机上的歌曲，这些地方迎合了我邮政编码区周围的各种群体。我会让餐馆里会说英语的人过来帮我翻译。我出生的国家正在遭受许多许多经济上的困难。即使我在那里感觉很糟糕。
In my country there are always flowers. That is my paradise. I won't change Puerto Rico by 16 of yorks. I won't change Puerto Rican chickens by frozen chickens in the ice boxes here. This is Max Nichols of Peter Marisburg, New Tell, South Africa, calling Tony Swartz of New York, USA. Hello, Tony Swartz. I'm bringing you greetings from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. This is a Greek folk show through Eilor Criter.
在我的国家，总是有花。那是我的天堂。我不会用16个纽约换波多黎各。我不会用冷冻鸡肉换波多黎各鸡肉。这是南非彼得马里茨堡的马克斯·尼科尔斯，致电美国纽约的托尼·施瓦茨。你好，托尼·施瓦茨。我从宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡给你带来问候。这是一个通过Eilor Criter的希腊民俗节目。
Hello, Tony. My name is Thomas Knott, 19th and Kalani, County Terry Island. When I got my first wire recorder, I asked the company if they would give me the guarantee slips from people from all over the world and all over this country who bought the recorders who said they were buying them because of their interest in music. And I would exchange wires with people in other countries who were interested in folk music and they would send me material from their countries. My name is Tony Schwartz. The music you hear is a Provean Indian playing his guitar on a quiet summer evening. This is one of 15,000 recordings I've collected. Recordings of folk music and folk music.
你好，托尼。我叫托马斯·诺特，住在泰瑞岛卡拉尼19号。当我得到第一台钢丝录音机时，我问公司是否可以给我来自世界各地和全国各地购买录音机的人的保修单，他们说他们购买是因为对音乐感兴趣。我会与对民间音乐感兴趣的其他国家的人交换钢丝录音，他们会寄给我来自他们国家的材料。我叫托尼·施瓦茨。你听到的音乐是一个普罗旺斯印第安人在一个安静的夏夜弹奏他的吉他。这是我收集的15000个录音之一。民间音乐和民间音乐的录音。
Recordings I've exchanged with people all over the world. Hello Tony, I received your letter here at the other day. Well I'm going to send you a wire and all this stuff that I generally do, you know, singing a comma and stuff. I don't know what you've been up to. New York City appreciate this kind of music. We folks around here do this hillbillie stuff. That's how it started. Recordings came in from all parts of the United States.
我与世界各地的人交换的录音。你好托尼，我前几天收到了你的信。好吧，我要给你寄一根钢丝和所有我通常做的东西，你知道，唱歌之类的。我不知道你在忙什么。纽约市欣赏这种音乐。我们这里的人做这种乡村音乐。这就是它的开始。录音来自美国各地。
From all parts of the world. Recordings on wire. Recordings on tape. One of my exchanges was with a man who wanted sounds he no longer heard. Tony, I wonder if you do me a favor. I live out in the country and originally I came from the city and I kind of miss it. I was wondering if you would record some sounds of the city and send them out to me. I'd really like to hear it. How about it? Part of my answer was recorded in
来自世界各地。钢丝录音。磁带录音。我的一次交换是和一个想要他不再听到的声音的人进行的。托尼，我想请你帮个忙。我住在乡下，最初我来自城市，我有点想念它。我想知道你是否能录下一些城市的声音寄给我。我真的很想听。怎么样？我的部分回答录制在
Times Square. Here's the thing. Bus car. I don't know. It's all on the old Christmas Village in the bar. The end part. A week later, I found this in my mailbox. Tony, I received your sounds of the city this morning, and I've been playing them ever since. I noticed that you said that you recorded them about 830 at night.
时代广场。事情是这样的。公交车。我不知道。都在酒吧里的旧圣诞村。最后一部分。一周后，我在邮箱里发现了这个。托尼，我今天早上收到了你的城市声音，从那以后我就一直在播放它们。我注意到你说你是晚上8点30分左右录制的。
To sort of reciprocate, here's the sounds of my country 830 at night. To sort of reciprocate, here's the sounds of my country 830 at night. The voices and music of the world came into my apartment in New York City, and I traveled no further than my mailbox. In people talking, there's an innate musicality in a way certain people speak. And also in the barcaries at nightclubs, various places. The sound of sewing used to be the people of vendors going by in the street or people singing in the backyard or shouting in the backyard.
为了礼尚往来，这是我国家晚上8点30分的声音。为了礼尚往来，这是我国家晚上8点30分的声音。世界的声音和音乐进入了我在纽约市的公寓，我没有走得比我的邮箱更远。在人们的谈话中，某些人说话的方式有一种天生的音乐性。还有在夜总会的酒吧里，各种地方。销售的声音曾经是街上走过的商贩，或者是后院里唱歌的人，或者是后院里大喊大叫的人。
Now, it's over the radio or television. I did a whole record on the sound of selling. VEGETAL MEN Apeles, apples on the street, or that horse and wagon selling vegetables. They were men who would go around buying old clothes and they'd go, I cash clothes, I cash go around buying old clothes and they go, I cash clothes, I cash clothes. It was February 3rd, 1956, when Tony Schwartz appeared at the information desk of the animal shelter to ask for a dog.
现在，它通过广播或电视传播。我做了一整张关于销售声音的唱片。蔬菜人，苹果，街上的苹果，或者那个卖蔬菜的马车。他们是那些会到处收购旧衣服的人，他们会喊，我收旧衣服，我收旧衣服。1956年2月3日，托尼·施瓦茨出现在动物收容所的咨询台询问狗的情况。
The attendant will take you into the adoption ward and ward a, look the dogs over and if there's anything you select, you tell them that's the dog you want. These are obedient, strange dogs working toward degrees, which of course, that's like receiving a college diploma. I did a radio program on sound once a week, on WNYC for over 35 years. I would do it on any subject that came up to me during the week.
服务员会带你去领养区，看看狗，如果你选择了什么，你就告诉他们那是你想要的狗。这些是听话的、奇怪的狗，正在努力获得学位，当然，这就像获得大学文凭一样。我在WNYC做了一个关于声音的广播节目，每周一次，持续了35年多。我会做任何我在那一周遇到的主题。
Good morning. Every year for the last 13 years I've been presenting the story and sound of the growth of my niece. We've all heard of time lapse photography. Well I'm going to apply this technique to the growth of my niece, Nancy, in sound. 13 years condensed into two minutes and 13 seconds. Here it goes. Jack and Jill went up the hill to fetch a pale of... What? Jack fell down and broke... And Jill came tumbling... What? How was it then? I would record the sound of my daughter growing up.
早上好。在过去的13年里，每年我都在展示我侄女成长的声音故事。我们都听说过延时摄影。好吧，我要把这种技术应用到我侄女南希的成长声音中。13年浓缩成2分13秒。开始了。杰克和吉尔上了山去取一桶……什么？杰克摔倒了，摔断了……吉尔滚了下来……什么？那时怎么样？我会录下我女儿成长的声音。
I have her first cries after being born. I had a microphone over her bed and a recorder in our bedroom. And any time I heard her beginning to wake up or anything I could turn on the recorder and record the sound of her waking up. Tony, if the dog makes a way we in house, if he has to make him a house broken if he makes away we in in the park and have to slap him with a newspaper then if he doesn't do it again he has broken.
我有她出生后的第一次哭声。我在她的床上方放了一个麦克风，在我们的卧室里放了一个录音机。每当我听到她开始醒来或什么的时候，我就可以打开录音机，录下她醒来的声音。托尼，如果狗在屋里排泄，如果他必须被训练成不在屋里排泄，如果他在公园里排泄，必须用报纸拍他，如果他不再那样做，他就被训练好了。
What do you think of the Russians sending the dog up in the satellite? Well I hope he doesn't get hurt but if he does I'm that I'll send up a medical satellite. Black woman was working as a nurse for our child. And when she'd go home at night, I'd take her out to get a cab to go up to Harlem. If she'd a helicopter, they wouldn't stop for her. Blacks couldn't get taxis to pick them up. And I interviewed cabs, drivers, why they don't like to go to Harlem. I put that in a program.
你觉得俄罗斯人把狗送上卫星怎么看？好吧，我希望他不会受伤，但如果他受伤了，我会送一个医疗卫星上去。黑人妇女在照顾我们的孩子。当她晚上回家时，我会带她去打车回哈莱姆。如果她有直升机，他们也不会为她停下来。黑人打不到出租车。我采访了出租车司机，为什么他们不喜欢去哈莱姆。我把那个放进了节目里。
It's all girls. You'll miss my hair, and it's very special for tonight. It's just the way I wanted to do a page board with a high top. And that's the way I like it. I'm taking guitar lessons, and that's fun. I take drama lessons after school, and that's great. And I've been working on the school newspaper. I might be editor next year. And I've been discovering boys.
全是女孩。你会想念我的头发，这对今晚来说很特别。这正是我想要做的高发髻。这就是我喜欢的样子。我正在上吉他课，那很有趣。我放学后上戏剧课，那很棒。我一直在为校报工作。明年我可能是编辑。我一直在发现男孩。
And I come to these ideas just from being human and working with sound and knowing how sound affected me and affected other people. Dear lies, Tony Chirney. Once a pet turtle, a dattle chirney, died February 24, 1964. Who died? My turtle, Tony. He got a soul shell and they tried to save him by giving him hamburger, but he died and we're gonna bury him Not too well Sort of a tragedy for me. I'm gonna play taps and the flag is because I like him
我产生这些想法只是因为我是一个人，与声音打交道，并且知道声音如何影响我以及影响其他人。亲爱的谎言，托尼·切尔尼。曾经有一只宠物龟，一只达特尔·切尔尼，死于1964年2月24日。谁死了？我的乌龟，托尼。他有一个软壳，他们试图通过给他汉堡包来救他，但他死了，我们要埋葬他。不太好。对我来说算是一场悲剧。我要吹熄灯号，还有旗帜，因为我喜欢他。
Just like the prison of the United States when he died except But he's like in my family. I'm a turtle. You're going to turtle. Blind. Come to me. My melon. Colley baby.
就像美国总统去世时一样，除了……但他就像我的家人。我是一只乌龟。你要去乌龟。瞎了。到我这来。我的甜瓜。科利宝贝。
Cut a lot. And don't be... Can't see be Can a baby shrivel? Anybody can feel blue. All your fears are foolish fancies, maybe. Well, I was born at the beginning of time. Time magazine started the year I was born. Harry Bolefonte was a pop singer when I met him. I got him into the Jamaican songs.
剪掉很多。不要……看不见吗？宝贝会枯萎吗？任何人都会感到忧郁。你所有的恐惧可能都是愚蠢的幻想。好吧，我出生在时间的开始。《时代》杂志在我出生的那一年创刊。我遇到哈里·贝拉方特时，他还是个流行歌手。我让他唱牙买加歌曲。
This is another working song. It is the banana loading song. Day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, night-o, day-o, night-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o, day-o And I played those songs the Arriba of Fonte. I got from a nightclub in Africa. Songs like Waymawaii. Remember that? And everybody loved Saturday night. Waymawaii I gave to the Weavers. And everybody loved Saturday night. I gave to which was name. He owns a casino in Atlantic City. He used to be a singer. He also, I watched Jeopardy on Toevers, and he ever watched that. And who was the guy that is the plunder of it? Merv Griffin, I gave him
这是另一首劳动歌曲。这是香蕉装载歌。Day-o, day-o... 我把那些歌放给贝拉方特听。我是在非洲的一家夜总会得到的。像《Waymawaii》这样的歌。还记得吗？每个人都喜欢周六晚上。《Waymawaii》我给了Weavers。每个人都喜欢周六晚上。我给了……他拥有大西洋城的一家赌场。他曾经是个歌手。我还看《危险边缘》，他看过那个吗？那个掠夺者是谁？默夫·格里芬，我给了他
everybody loves Saturday night. Good morning. Today I'd like to play two beautiful songs sung by Paul Robson. I think he was one of the great singers of our time. In the McCarthy era, Robson couldn't travel because they called him a communist, which is ridiculous. He wasn't a communist, which is ridiculously what a communist. Just believed in internationalism. He wanted to send tapes to various places around the world.
每个人都喜欢周六晚上。早上好。今天我想播放两首保罗·罗伯逊演唱的美丽歌曲。我认为他是我们这个时代最伟大的歌手之一。在麦卡锡时代，罗伯逊不能旅行，因为他们称他为共产主义者，这很荒谬。他不是共产主义者，这很荒谬。只是相信国际主义。他想把磁带寄到世界各地。
One I did to send to England for a speech for him. It was about peace, so I had his song behind it. Then I had his narration over that. Peace and friendship with our great wartime ally, and enduring peace growing out of United Nations, out of friendship with the Soviet people. I did it for many people who couldn't travel for W.E.B. Du Bois. I would record speeches that he wanted to give in South Africa. Dr. W. E. B. Du Bois of New York writer and president of the Penn African Congress to the peoples of Africa, greeting.
我做了一个寄到英国的演讲磁带。是关于和平的，所以我把他的歌放在后面。然后我把他的叙述放在上面。与我们伟大的战时盟友和平与友谊，从联合国中成长出的持久和平，与苏联人民的友谊。我为许多不能旅行的人做了这件事，为W.E.B.杜波依斯做了这件事。我会录下他想在南非发表的演讲。纽约作家、泛非大会主席W.E.B.杜波依斯博士致非洲人民，问候。
Then when the Hollywood 10 was supposed to go to jail for being un-American and many of them had made movies that I loved, I recorded all of them the night before they went to jail. Dalton Trombone telling what he was accused of. How did they treat you in Trombone? The committee was anti-Semitic, anti-labor, anti-need girl, pro-war, and had been denounced by everyone from Roosevelt down over the world. The ridiculousness of this McCarthy era, you know, he started the whole thing of loyalty oaths. Most people think of evil as the sounds of gunfire or thunder or lightning or something.
然后当好莱坞十君子因为被指控不爱国而要入狱时，他们中的许多人制作了我喜欢的电影，我在他们入狱的前一天晚上录下了他们所有人。道尔顿·特朗勃讲述了他被指控的内容。特朗勃，他们怎么对待你？委员会是反犹太的、反劳工的、反……亲战的，并且被从罗斯福到世界各地的每个人谴责。这个麦卡锡时代的荒谬，你知道，他开始了忠诚宣誓的整个事情。大多数人认为邪恶是枪声、雷声或闪电之类的声音。
I've found and believe that the most evil sounds in the world are the sounds out of mouths of people. Why have you used media to shame people into proper behavior? In primitive cultures, if someone did something shameful, and word of mouth got around the village in an hour or so, in our culture, the same thing exists, but if you divide the distance of our country into the speed of sound, you find they would take a 64th of a second to reach across the country by telephone, radio, television or anything like that. I did a commercial with a pope against nuclear weapons. I've been against nuclear weapons since 1939.
我发现并相信世界上最邪恶的声音是人们嘴里发出的声音。你为什么要利用媒体羞辱人们以使其行为得当？在原始文化中，如果有人做了丢脸的事，消息在一个小时左右就会传遍村庄，在我们的文化中，同样的事情也存在，但如果你把我们国家的距离除以声音的速度，你会发现通过电话、广播、电视或任何类似的东西传遍全国需要64分之一秒。我做了一个教皇反对核武器的广告。自1939年以来，我一直反对核武器。
One thing I've done was the daisy spot for President Johnson. I was working on sound for six or seven commercials in the campaign against Barry Goldwater. One of them was a little girl counting down and picking the pedals off her daisy, then there's the countdown and then the blonde goes off. Harold, these are the stakes to make a world in which all of God's children can live. Aren't to go into the dark. We must either love each other or we must die. What would you say to young people who smoke? I would say that they're very foolish even to consider it I had to have my voice box removed I have a whole micraote that's what I teach a course for NYU
我做的一件事是为约翰逊总统做的雏菊广告。我在竞选活动中为六七个反对巴里·戈德华特的广告制作声音。其中一个是小女孩倒数并摘下雏菊的花瓣，然后是倒计时，然后炸弹爆炸。哈罗德，这就是创造一个上帝所有孩子都能生活的世界的赌注。不要进入黑暗。我们必须相爱，否则我们必须死亡。你会对吸烟的年轻人说什么？我会说他们甚至考虑吸烟是非常愚蠢的。我不得不切除我的声带，我有一个完整的麦克风，这就是我在纽约大学教的一门课程。
I also teach median public health in Harvard both places come here. I have a Gauravphobia. I don't travel. I'm not able to travel. I have used the telephone to teach all over the world in Sweden, in Japan, South America, Australia. My brother built a one tube radio which never worked and I used to go up in the attic and play a spaceship like Jack Armstrong. I was also interested in physics and the physics teacher was interested in amateur radio. And I first built my own receivers and huge 20 meter antennas.
我还教哈佛大学的媒体公共卫生，两个地方都来这里。我有广场恐惧症。我不旅行。我不能旅行。我利用电话在世界各地教学，在瑞典、日本、南美、澳大利亚。我哥哥造了一个从不工作的单管收音机，我过去常去阁楼上玩像杰克·阿姆斯特朗那样的太空船。我也对物理感兴趣，物理老师对业余无线电感兴趣。我第一次建造了自己的接收器和巨大的20米天线。
And I built my own little shack where I had 16 by 16. And I had my radio station in the front, my bed in the back. And I ran a telephone line up to the house so my mother could call me in for supper. I made up short way of listening cards, I speak to them on radio, and I would tell them how they're coming in. I think the most important thing we can work on in communication is to make the world safer for the people who live with it. People, that's what I was most interested in. People in their life, what they do.
我建造了自己的小屋，16乘16。我的无线电台在前面，我的床在后面。我拉了一条电话线到房子里，这样我妈妈就可以叫我吃晚饭。我制作了短波收听卡，我在无线电上与他们交谈，我会告诉他们他们的信号接收情况。我认为我们在通信方面可以做的最重要的事情是让世界对生活在其中的人们更安全。人们，那是我最感兴趣的。人们的生活，他们做什么。
Tony Schwartz, 30,000 recordings later, was produced by the kitchen sisters, David and Elson and Nikki Silva, with El from Tim Burby, Nina Ellis and Jim Anderson. Mixed by Jim McKee at Earwax Productions in San Francisco. This week, Lost and Found Sound thanks, Reena Schwartz, Gabriel Lewis, and Stations KQED and WNYC. Tony Schwartz died in 2008.
《托尼·施瓦茨，30000次录音之后》由Kitchen Sisters、戴维·尼尔森和尼基·席尔瓦制作，蒂姆·伯比、尼娜·埃利斯和吉姆·安德森提供帮助。由旧金山Earwax Productions的吉姆·麦基混音。本周，“失而复得的声音”感谢里娜·施瓦茨、加布里埃尔·刘易斯以及KQED和WNYC电台。托尼·施瓦茨于2008年去世。
You can still buy his amazing recordings on iTunes. They're worth every penny as you get them. Thanks to the kitchen sisters for introducing me to him, Nikki Silva and Davian Nelson are total heroes to me. Their podcast is a central listening, it's called Fugitive Waves. 99% of visible is Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, an architecture and interior sperm in beautiful downtown Oakland,
你仍然可以在iTunes上购买他精彩的录音。它们物有所值，非常值得购买。感谢Kitchen Sisters向我介绍了他，Nikki Silva和Davian Nelson对我来说是真正的英雄。他们的播客是必听节目，名字叫Fugitive Waves。《99% Invisible》的制作团队包括Katie Mingle、Sam Greenspan、Avery Trufelman，以及我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑与室内设计公司Arxnes的办公室里制作完成，
California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% In. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州。你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括精美的图片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。RadioTopia。来自PRX。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。